What Kara Keller did,
and two,
one,
two,
eight to 1280 was only the final apt
long process which started when the
founder of Rome Romulus welcomed
refugees and asylum seekers to his new
city by the Tiber to be proper Roman
citizens,
which carried on as citizenship was
spread among those whom Rome conquered,
and when people from far of field became
Roman emperors,
Trajan and Hadrian from Spain,
Septimius severus from North Africa,
that could never have happened at
Athens,
and at the same time,
slaves in their millions were fruit at
Rome,
at in the process completely unlike in
the Greek world.
They became full Roman citizens.
Many fewer slaves wherever fried in
Athens or any of the Greek states in
which we know,
and if they were freed,
they certainly didn't become citizens.
This was an incorporated community.
Now,
some observant people in Greece early on
spotted these weird habits of the Romans
and they were amazed.
A few of the smartest began to think
that maybe Roman openness was the secret
of her success,
and that's what I think.
I think too.
I think robes real Rome's rough.
It's in your face.
It's open,
it's welcoming,
and it's us.
Thank you.
Thanks.